تطلب مدينة أماريلو بولاية تكساس من
الناس تخمين ما هو هذا
الشيء الذي تم التقاط الصورة به الشهر الماضي في الساعة 1
25 صباحًا بواسطة كاميرا تم إعدادها داخل
حديقة حيوانات أماريلو
تبحث عن سياج محيط ، هل
هو شخص يرتدي قبعة غريبة يحب ذلك؟
سأل المسؤولون في المدينة في
تغريدة على تويتر مشيرًا إليها على أنها
uao كائن أماريلو المجهول.
يتم تنشيط الكاميرا
وترسل تنبيهًا إلى مسؤولي حديقة الحيوان عندما
تلتقط شيئًا ما كان هناك بعض
النظريات الجادة
عن راكون يقف على رجليه الخلفيتين أو من
المحتمل أن شخصًا يمشي في
الحديقة والذي حدث للتو تم التقاطه
بطريقة غريبة
ولكن تخمينات الجمهور كانت  أكثر
سخونة من سونيك القنفذ إلى
تميمة الذئب في سان
أنطونيو  هو
رجل طليق وبالطبع كانت هناك
إشارات إلى القدم
الكبيرة التي يعتقد شخص ما أن القدم الصغيرة قد تكون أكثر
ملاءمة ،
لا يوجد فيديو فقط هذه الصورة
خرج أحد الملصقات لتوضيح
نظريته أنه كان ذئبًا يقفز على السياج
مخططًا بتشريح مثل ذيل الأذنين
وما إلى ذلك  لاحظ ما
إذا كان لا شيء آخر كل هذه التخمينات يمكن أن
تترك الناس عواء
geniemose cnn نيويورك